what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay Rob core we're going to be
dangerous we're going to be dangerous
some of you might love me some of you
might hate me we're going to do the
button but we're going to do one video
for each of the comics so one in two
time out today and then three and four
should come out later on this week
probably Thursday maybe Wednesday I'm
not sure but we're going to try this and
we're going to see what happens because
there's only four issues it's not like
it's six or something it's going to take
us you know days to do it'll take us a
couple days and so I figured we go ahead
and give it a shot let the button oh my
god - this story is so good it's one of
the most anticipated stories I've been
looking forward to it for a long time
but I think it's one of the most
anticipated stories of DC rebirth
because this finally gives us some
measure of answering the question what's
going on with the button now for those
of you guys who are just now joining in
the DC comics landscape because the
button is really kind of a big talking
point among the kind of book community
we don't know we need to Matt's going on
all we know is that in DC Universe
rebirth number one when the button that
previously belonged to the comedian
before he died in the Watchmen comics
suddenly appeared in the Batcave it's
set in motion nothing but speculation
about The Watchmen about what was going
on we had this emic mattock guy mr. oz
who was talking about people that are in
the new 52 universe that should be there
about how things are screwed up and so
on and so forth but we literally know
nothing about what's going on the only
thing that this has given us is the idea
that in some form or fashion the
Watchmen are being folded into the DC
Universe and so the idea that people had
is that maybe it was dr. Manhattan who
had messed with all these things that
according to Wally West somebody took
ten years away from everybody's life and
we didn't know who it was so maybe it
was Manhattan maybe it was nil at least
of your saddle over a comic pop you
believe that mr. Oz is the pre new 52
Lex Luthor which I love that idea but
it's just it's speculation reigning
supreme which is really half the fun but
the button thing is is so cool the story
is so amazing so um initially we pick up
with Saturn girl Saturn girl is part of
the Legion of super-heroes they're
superheroes from the 31st century
they're from the future now all we
really know about her in terms of the DC
landscape is that in DC Universe rebirth
number one in Batman number nine or
Batman rebirth thrown on and in this
story we've seen her in Arkham Asylum
we don't know why she's there we don't
know who put her there it seems like
she's there against her will we have no
idea what's going on all we know is that
she's there
but it's so ironic that she's in a home
for the mentally insane because Saturn
girl being from the future would likely
know how these events are going to play
out now again this deals a little bit in
terms of like retcons and stuff like
that because non comic readers were
asked a question well if she knew this
was going to play out then why didn't
she tell anybody about it before well
because this is a new introduction to
comics so again somebody's kind of
messing with things but the fact remains
here it's like a ripple effect it's like
a scarf act right like like if time were
linear alright there were no alternate
realities or anything like that if I go
back to you and I meet you when you're
five years old and I cut your hand then
at 50 years old when I went back in time
in the first place you would suddenly
see a scarf here on your hand out of
nowhere it's just basically the fact of
the past influences the future and so
because of that you know most likely we
would have to believe that as she's from
the 31st century that her memories what
automatically be updated to reflect
whatever it is it's going to happen with
regards to the Watchmen now we know that
she has an understanding of the future
because of the fact that she's watching
a hockey game unfold and in this hockey
game one of the players gets killed but
no one comes and saves a Superman no
Justice League no nothing it's just a
guy dies during a hockey game but the
reason why this was introduced is
because it is Calm keying basically kind
of throwing in this whole idea of
allowing the narrative of the story to
be reflected by the hockey game because
with the narrative or at least with the
broadcast as is given to us it's okay
here's the opening salvo like the puck
is down the players are playing you know
and they start kind of going back and
forth alright let's pass the puck to
disk I cast the puck to that guy the
puck representing information
speculation the idea of what's going to
happen the knowledge of what this button
represents is kind of going back and
forth but the hockey team also
represents players in the DC Universe
superheroes the Justice League so on and
so forth the opposing team perhaps even
the Watchmen it was kind of cool to see
this unfold because what is it happening
early ceylon we initially saw Saturn
girl she was screaming about how people
were going to die the Legion of
super-heroes was going to die DC's main
superhero teams were going to die
everybody was going to die and no one
could do anything to stop it and so the
indication seems to be here that like
the home hockey team going against the
the opposing hockey team the home guys
are the superheroes the opposing team is
the watchman or dr. Manhattan or
whatever they happen to represent and
the home superheroes are getting
obliterated and somebody significant is
going to die now of course this entire
time Batman is really just kind of
meddling around and messing around with
a button that belong to the comedian but
the crazy thing about this is
that while messing with the button it
suddenly has this interaction with the
mask of psycho-pirate now this is one of
the reasons that I'm really glad we
covered that man rebirth you know when
with all the different stories and
things like that you'll find that
playlist down in the description because
this is going to go in the Watchmen
playlist but inside that playlist we
also have everything from you know
before watching release all the videos
we've done before Watchmen as well as
the whole discussion about you know
Batman and flash and so on and so forth
but the doctor mains here with the
psycho pirates mask is not really the
psycho pirates mask so much it's called
the Medusa mask and what it does is it
basically manipulates the emotions of
others by reflecting its own face so if
the reducer mask will take on the face
of sadness and that individual who is
looking upon the Medusa mask will feel
sadness the same thing with happiness
anger you know remorse so on and so
forth compassion that whole thing and so
because of that the button reacting with
the mask results in Bruce Wayne seeing
his father Thomas Wayne from the
flashpoint
universe and that's why things are so
crazy now if you're new and you never
saw my flashpoint videos you'll find
those on the playlist as well everything
that you need to understand what's going
on right now is in that playlist so I
got to do is go there click play and
you'll be caught up but assuming that
you don't really have a chance to do
that or you don't really have a whole
lot of time the flashpoint universe was
a byproduct of Barry Allen remember the
flashpoint universe is basically what
initiated the new 52 Barry Allen went
back in time to save his mom's life and
was successful in doing so but because
of the fact that she survived and
because Barry Allen essentially never
became a flash the motivation for him
being the flash never existed ultimately
it led to him just being a normal human
being but it also spawned a wholly
different universe that saw a very dark
scenario we ended up seeing that the
Atlanteans MD amazons ended up going to
war with one another Superman never
became Superman he landed he was
discovered by the US government and he
was held underground in stasis for
almost his entire life one of the most
significant developments in the
flashpoint universe was that instead of
Bruce Wayne's parents dying having been
shot to death instead Bruce Wayne was
killed his father became Batman and his
mother became the Joker and so it was so
cool it was so awesome such an amazing
piece of storytelling for us to be able
to see but this illusion is basically
Batman seeing his father as he existed
in the flashpoint universe now of course
that begs the question of all the ways
in which he could envision
mother why is he seeing the flashpoint
version you would think that if it was a
hallucination you would think that his
father in his mind's eye manifested in a
physical form it would happen by way of
him seeing his father as he remembers
him so again it's basically Keane
telling us that everything you're seeing
is the way you would expect it to see
and there's a lot more at play here and
so of course what is up happening and
this is when we get to the one minute
window when everything happens in the
span of one minute Bruce Wayne contacts
the flash says hey this button that
we've been looking at it had a reaction
to lego pirates Medusa mask I need you
to get over here so we can analyze it
and we can see what's going on the flash
says okay I'm dealing with these bad
guys I'll be over there the clock starts
one minute from the time this clock
starts and to the time we get to the end
of this comic everything takes place in
the span of one minute and the craziest
thing about this is that immediately
almost immediately after this
conversation ends Batman hangs up the
ends up seeing a spark of lightning has
thought is that it's very allen and it's
not it's a Abarth on the reverse flash
now one of the big questions that a lot
of current flash readers are going to
have is how is this eobard thawne eobard
thawne is locked up in iron Heights we
saw that in the flash story he's
currently in prison his current version
is in prison one of the craziest things
when it comes to yeah Bart Thawne is he
is intrinsically tied into time-travel
and so while the present-day eobard
thawne is stuck in prison in three hours
or five hours or three days or five days
or a month or even you know 15 years
from now he ends up getting free
somewhere along line we don't know how
and it's not really important what we
know is that this is eobard thawne being
hear from at some point in the past or
possibly even in the in the future and
so eobard thawne because of how he
exists because he's so immersed in
trying to travel it's entirely possible
for him to exist in two places at the
same time and so what is up happening
here is that he starts talking to Batman
about how a greater power had called out
to him it had basically reached out to
him and he was essentially resurrected
and so the funny thing about this is
Batman faces off against you know eobard
thawne as best he can but he doesn't
stand a chance I mean eobard thawne is a
struggle for Barry Allen to be and Barry
Allen is wildly powerful in terms of it
you know it's speeding capabilities of
so on and so forth dare I say one of the
most powerful members of the Justice
League Batman is just a guy with
resources and stuff but being caught off
guard being hit five six seven times in
the span of a second makes it virtually
impossible for him to provide any kind
of counter punch any kind of offer to
what it is that you have our dawn is
doing now what ends up happening is that
eobard thawne actually discovers the
letter that Batman received from his
father and that was a part of the
flashpoint story when the flashpoint
story began to come to an end
Thomas Wayne had basically written a
note for his son and given and gave it
to Barry Allen the reason being because
of the fact the Barry Allen when he met
Thomas Wayne as Batman in the flashpoint
universe and hey look this is not how
things are supposed to be and the
universe that I come from you and your
wife died and your son became Batman and
so the result is that Thomas wrote a
letter to his son he gave it to Barry
Allen Barry Allen went back in time
stopped himself from saving his mother's
life things more or less went back to
normal but resulted in the new 52 reboot
but at the end of flashpoint he gave
Thomas Waynes note to Bruce Wayne and
for one of the only times in the history
of DC Comics Bruce Wayne cried it was an
emotional moment it was really probably
probably the best possible ending to
that story was it was insanely well done
but in the midst of all this eobard
thawne more or less kind of makes fun of
Batman and then just rips it all up now
eobard thawne starts saying things like
you know did it make you feel better
Thomas and things like that the reason
why is because of the fact that within
the flashpoint universe eobard thawne
was there
eobard thawne taunted Barry Allen you
know eobard thawne and very kind of went
hand in hand in that particular story
again we're leaving a little bit out
here in terms of flashpoint but of
course like I said we have those videos
you're welcome to go back and watch them
and get the full impact of the story
itself and so here bar dawn knew who
thomas wayne was mostly because of the
fact that thomas wayne was the one that
killed him so because of that he's
pretty he's pretty aware of who thomas
wayne is but the fact remains here that
batman having a letter from his father
to rip to pieces and thrown away it's
crushing I mean it's absolutely crushing
for him because it's the last connection
he had to his dad the last connection
that he had to him now of course Batman
seizes the opportunity to basically you
know stab the abarth on in the foot and
is kind of keep him pinned to the ground
and then just speed him up a little bit
but ultimately what we end up finding
out is the whole purpose of Batman
fighting against eobard thawne was to
serve as a distraction the distraction
being what was supposed to be the
arrival of Barry Allen the problem with
this is that in the middle of this whole
thing
eobard thawne picks up the button and
vanishes disappears returns and in
probably the greatest points one of the
greatest points of this whole story he
starts freaking out about how he saw God
he's like I saw God if he just starts
losing his mind and then just sort of
explodes and this massive you know
melting deterioration of Speed Force
lightning and then Barry Allen simply
just shows up after it's all said and
done keep in mind from the time this
this comics started to the time is
coming finished it's maybe been five
minutes maybe five minutes probably more
along the lines of like three or four
but it is so cool to see it has happen
because Barry Allen suddenly gets here
he's like why don't know how happened
why what
one minute you call me and the next
eobard thawne is laying dead and you're
clinging on to dear life and so now the
question becomes who killed
reverse-flash what and the world
happened without being said guys we're
going to bring this video to an end if
you are new here to come as explained
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob Ford if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]